what's your favorite thing about New
York City you can never find someone
even if they're the biggest Homer of
where they're from that doesn't wildly
Love New York you can't say that about
LA or London or Paris these incredible
other places it is the one Universal
City of the world and I think that has
to do with a lot of the actual love that
sits underneath the tough exterior that
a lot of people think about as well
that's what we found doing this show
just talking to people it's everyone has
a huge heart in New York City and
there's this underlying kindness that
even though people are like rough around
the edges New York might be one of the
worst branded places and this is like
the most loving inclusive epic place
I've ever been a part of so if you look
deeply if you peel away from that Apple
a little see what I did there if you
peel a little bit from the Apple you'll
see an incredible amount of love and
that's my favorite part of New York